content marketing is a strategic
approach in creating and sharing
valuable audience focused content to
build brand awareness engage customers
and drive growth it involves diverse
content formats SE optimization and
consistent distribution content
marketing is a long-term strategy that
requires adaptability and a focus on
providing value to your target audience
on an average a Content marketer earns
up to
$72,000 per year content marketing is
becoming a key player in the digital
marketing domain if you are looking to
grab a successful career in content
marketing but not limited to content
marketing simply learn has got you
covered with wide range of topnotch
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands on experience in
tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner Sam rush and there is a huge
list on the board however one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
this course find the course Link in the
description box so before we move ahead
consider subscribing to Simply learn and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from us so without any further
delay over to our tutors I'm Greg jarbo
and what is that I mean what we're going
to talk about in this first module of a
Content marketing Foundation course is
literally content marketing um okay what
is it so content marketing Is Not A New
Concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know little refresh
Russia right now were two brothers who
made pneumatic tires and they were
trying to sell them along with an
Innovative product at its time called
the
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my God what was worth going out
there for you know rep Paris that's all
Happening Here and what the Michelin
Brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more
tires they had to get people to drive
farther and farther and use them so what
did they come up with the concept that
really is the birth of content Marketing
in my
book was the Michelin
guide and the Michelin guide was unique
in that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to die for the Ratatouille H you
you got to have it this is a three star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way and since we're
going to give you a guide and you have
to get out of Paris in order to get
there we're going to tell you where you
can find gasoline along the way uh which
hotels uh you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a Pneumatic and you know
what it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the feat features and benefits
of
round or a tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to Their audience about
what Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in
1900 was
food and by creating
content but got the audience to get into
their new Innovative Auto
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three star
restaurant people got more Flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the
way Michelin solds more tires so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of you know hit a pause and like well
we're doing content marketing we need to
come up with a concept think back to the
Michelin guide it's it's a great
foundation so let's go to a modern
definition where are we now in the 21st
century when it comes to content
marketing well you can read the slide
here and read the definition and some
people like reading definitions I'm not
going to read it to you but I am going
to highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are
absolutely critical to any definition of
content marketing
the content that you create needs to be
relevant and it also has to be
valuable now if it's not relevant then
you're not actually meeting my needs or
interests you know and why would I be
interested in it and we've gotten way
too tired of screening out the
commercial that comes on um you know
trying to sell us snow tires and pardon
me we live in Florida I don't use snow
TIR tires what the what the heck is this
commercial doing you know interrupting
what I'm
watching so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out and the
valuable the valuable can can work in a
lot of different ways it could be
interesting it can be useful you know
value is an interesting proposition all
by
itself but that's the key to content
marketing uh it's not just creating more
spam it's not just throwing more trash
over the fence and hoping something
happens this is something where if
you've created valuable and relevant
content you know what your customers
will find you it's a whole different
kind of
proposition I know there's some Skeptics
who saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module
3 but let me just be clear
here social media content is part of
what content marketing needs to create
but it can also create content for your
website and that's not the social media
it can also create content that um your
PR people can share with uh uh reporters
or bloggers and that's not normally
considered uh social media content and
by the way all of that content can be
optimized so maybe it actually is part
of SEO not social media marketing in
fact that's the other place that content
marketing really
overlaps and it's not
coincidental it so happens that around
February
2011 when Google rolled out the first of
its multiple versions of the panda
update
all of a sudden even seos started to pay
attention to content marketing why
because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant you
know what it's not going to rank very
well in our search
algorithm and all of a sudden people who
had been used to like putting keywords
in the right places realized content
matters you mean I've got to actually
tell stories that are interesting I've
got to create information that's
valuable yeah yeah you can make it
relevant that's the optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash God bless you good
luck so yeah content
marketing has grown it's like tripled in
terms of web search interest since the
panda update and we're talking about
Panda 1 of course there was Panda 2
Panda 3 Panda 4 I mean come on Google
SCH is driving us in this direction and
so content marketing is pretty relevant
today now one of the other things that
uh people in content marketing struggle
with is oh but you don't understand I do
B2B content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right well possibly maybe on
occasion so let's just question that
assumption for a
second you know content marketing has
been around now long enough and enough
people have done it but some research
has been conducted and it's been
conducted against b2c marketers and B2B
marketers and small business marketers
and Enterprise level
marketers and when they start asking key
questions like okay we're going to try
to determine what is the difference
between an effective content marketer
and an ineffective content
marketer let's see the results well
first of all the most important thing to
Be an Effective B Toc content
marketer is you need a documented
content
strategy oh okay all right mean people
who are winging it aren't as uh
effective as people who actually have
thought about this and written it down
got it okay no great Insight but you
know interesting to note secondly they
got to have somebody in charge who
oversees content marketing oh Lord does
that mean we have to have a reorg or
maybe we just have to designate somebody
who reports to somebody else whatever
but guess what it really helps if
somebody is driving this
process third they've got to be using
more content marketing tactics than
their less effective
appears and this is not an argument more
is better this is just pardon me that's
the way the data falls out the people
who are actually more effective are
doing more different kinds of
things a broader range of
tactics and who knows maybe it's that
broader range that's part of the success
formula same thing is true with social
media
platforms the effective content
marketers are using more than the
ineffective ones and last but not least
and this may be a sort of a result of
the first four by gosh effective content
marketers generally have greater
percentage of the overall marketing
budget in their
organization wow okay that's the BTC
marketing form but you don't understand
I'm not a b2c
marketer okay so let's take a look at
the B2B content marketing formula
guess what you need to have a documented
content marketing strategy to Be an
Effective B2B content marketer you need
to have someone who oversees content
marketing strategy it helps if you are
using more tactics and more social media
platforms and guess what you spend a
higher percentage of your overall
marketing Budget on content marketing
well that's similar to the B Toc content
marketers but do you understand B2B is
different yeah there's a couple small
differences but guess what overall the
top five criteria are similar and when
you get to small business here's what
you're going to see same five
criteria and you're in an Enterprise I
know the world is different for
Enterprises actually not so much so four
different data points let's net it out
there's a pattern and the pattern is is
I don't care what flavor of content
marketer you are you can be B Toc B2B
you can be small business you can be
large Enterprise at the end of the day
there are five things that you've got to
focus on if you want to be
effective we've already covered these
and are there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
B2B and b2c well
sure but they're all at the
margin what's the downside if we don't
do this you know is anyone going to come
in and like whack us and the answer is
um maybe not inside your boardroom but
it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your salespeople makes they
may encounter someone I like to call the
man in the chair and the Man in the
chair actually refers back to a classic
McGraw Hill ad campaign from I think the
1960s but basically the guy in the chair
asks the ically some questions from
quote maybe your salesperson okay I
don't know anything about you I don't
know about your company I don't know
about your company's product I don't
know about your company's you know
reputation or anything about you and so
what was it you were going to try to
sell me and that's the downside of not
having a Content marketing
program we've actually found and work
that we've done with companies that
content marketing can shorten the sales
cycle why you're providing people with
information at key points that they need
in order to take the next
step so yeah is there a downside sure
stick with the status quo struggle
swimming against the tide you know what
it's probably smarter to have a Content
marketing
program so this introductory module in
the content marketing Foundation try to
ask and answer these
questions what is content
marketing and oh by the way just how
different are b2c B2B small business and
Enterprise content
marketing and I think you've got the
answer content marketing u means that
your
content needs to be relevant
and it needs to be
valuable and by the way that content can
come in a whole lot of different forms
it's not just words on paper it can be
videos it can be infographics it can be
webinars it can be speeches that your
executives are giving in public you know
content can take a lot of different
forms but at the end of the
day you want to Be an Effective content
marketer and for that we're going to go
through five more modules and let me
give you a sort of a highlight of what
we're going to
cover guess what we're going to cover
all the things that makes you effective
we're going to cover content marketing
strategy you need a documented one so
we'll we'll go through that and by the
way we're going to have a little extra
bonus because it's a problem that we've
seen people encounter again and again
which is all right before we've ever
done this in my organization I need to
get a budget for like a pilot project
how do I do that what do I do when I
don't have a budget and I'm trying to
start up content Marketing in my
organization so that's going to be
covered in module two module three we're
going to talk about someone who oversees
content marketing yeah right the org
chart and what we're really going to
focus in and this happens more in larger
Enterprise than other organizations but
even smaller businesses someday aspire
to be medium-sized businesses and
mediumsized businesses want to grow up
to be large Enterprises so you know what
it's probably useful for all of us to
understand where this is headed and
we'll talk about the lack of
integration across the marketing mix
both within the organization but also
outside when it comes to uh
communicating to customers and why guess
what maybe it's time to organize a
little differently third we'll talk
about all those content marketing
tactics and instead of just listing them
all because you know what lists are
interesting but they're not persuasive
what we're going to look at are the
content marketing tactics that content
marketers consider most
effective so that WIS down the list and
you're going to want to take some time
and learn not just the broad range of
things you could be doing but the ones
that seem to move the needle and then
then we'll tackle the sort of subsidiary
question of how do I produce a variety
of content you know that seems to be a
problem for some folks well trust me
once you get your handle uh your arms
around um the whole what is effective
the variety of content pretty much takes
care of itself in the fifth module we're
going to take a look at social media
platforms and again content marketers
are experimenting with a wide variety of
them um the list seems to change daily
as new ones are introduced or suddenly
the the list is wise because uh some
social media platform just got acquired
but now the company that acquired it is
you know pretty big and pretty
interesting so maybe we need to pay
attention to that too well guess what
once again we're going to do a little
triage here we're only going to look at
the ones that seem to be most effective
today and you too may want to experiment
with other ones beyond that what it
helps to have as a core part of your
content marketing programs the ones that
are the most effective and then guess
what the challenge is not having one the
challenge is actually producing engaging
content for those social media platforms
so we'll look at that in module five and
in module six we're going to talk about
budgets why because it all comes down to
the budget you got to have one and by
the way you need to be spending a larger
uh percentage of your marketing Budget
on content Marketing in order to be
effective and in order to do that we're
going to have to skin this cat we're
going to have to look at measurement
we're going to have to get you over the
hurdle of how come it is so hard to
measure the
effectiveness of my content you know how
do I know that when when can I turn
around and show that to the top
management so I can say wow that moved
the needle fine you need a bigger budget
next year you got it so that's what's
coming um stay tuned uh strap in this is
uh going to be a bumpy ride at times but
guess what
it is a journey worth taking in the
world of digital marketing you must have
heard the term
copyrighting but very few people talk
about copyrighting it's one of the
essential skills for any digital
marketer it has been estimated that
there are 1 lakh 31,200 copywriters in
the United States today it is projected
that the copyrighting job market will
grow by 7.6% from
2016 to
2026 freelance market for copyrighting
is onor role companies like upwork and
F4 are filled with copywriters there are
many advantages of freelance
copyrighting jobs like being Your Own
Boss a flexible schedule and doing what
you love in this video we will try to
understand the art of copyrighting in
very simple manner if you stick to this
video till the end I assure you that you
will have a good understanding of
copyrighting hey everyone I'm tab Bal
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that b Bell icon to stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session we will start off the session
with an overview of what copyrighting is
what does a copywriter do then its
various types next we will understand
the difference between copyrighting and
content writing moving forward we will
discuss the best tools for copywriters
can use and finally we will end the
session by discussing the job scenario
and salary of a
copywriter so let's begin with our first
topic what is copyrighting in simple
words copyrighting is a type of writing
or a set of words that will convince the
reader to take some kind of action and
that action can be anything like
registering for an event signing up for
something or buying a product businesses
usually hire copywriters to write
landing pages Facebook and Google ads
copy social media post Etc in order to
convince the readers to take some action
copy writing should be part of any
marketing plan and is one of the most
powerful ways to capture the attention
of your target audience and motivate
them to convert or purchase copyrighting
is everywhere when you go online or even
offline remember the Google ad that you
see when you search for something in
Google that is a copy or if you check
your email box you will find different
promotional mails by different companies
that are a copy basically those
companies are trying to convince you to
take some action it can be anything for
example an e-commerce company will
convince you to purchase some of their
store products now let's talk about the
copyrighting formula a good copy usually
follows Aida formula
a stands for attention I for interest D
for desire and a for Action almost every
good copywriter uses this formula to
write better copies and it's important
for you in case you decided to become a
copywriter or want to use copyrighting
in some of your work so I hope now we
understand what actually copyrighting is
now let's try to understand what does a
copywriter actually do the copy writer's
job is to write words that convince an
audience to take some action for the
benefit of the company in which the
writer Works let's have a look at sample
copyrighted job description that will
help you understand the role and
responsibilities and the skills needed
for this role so firstly let's have a
look at responsibilities writing editing
and Publishing engaging content for
various social media Network including
Facebook Twitter Instagram LinkedIn and
Google my business optimizing social
media post language tone message based
on your target audience Behavior
selecting appealing images and videos to
complement text for designers to design
the
post let's have a look at some more
responsibilities coordinate with
internal teams to create advertising
post for client respond to questions and
comments on social media Pages promptly
and accurately there can be more
responsibilities to a copywriter
depending on what the company needs so
it varies from company to company now
let's see what skills a company looks
for in a
copywriter hands-on experience using
various social media platform to
advertise solid knowledge of SEO keyword
research and analytics tools example
Google analytics familiarity with online
paid advertising let's have a look of
some others requirement and
skills ability to deliver creative web
content text image and video excellent
communication
skills so now we know what copywriter
does let's explore its various types SEO
copyrighting it means optimizing the
copy using keywords to make it rank at
the top of the search results for
example if you optimize a company's
product page correctly through SEO
copyrighting then there is a high
chances that your sales page would rank
at the top of the search result which
would result in more sales next we have
social media copyrighting this type of
copyrighting is used on social media
platform for example a catchy title is
used to grab the attention of the user
and Emoji is used to make the copy
interesting or frame the right message
in order to convince the audience to
take some kind of action next we we have
technical copyrighting the motive for
writing technical copy is to explain the
latest Technologies or the technical
product that a company wants to sell for
example if you have a tech product you
need a copywriter who can explain the
technical aspect use case of the product
and how that product help the customer
direct response copyrighting it is a
type of communication that is compelling
enough to be able to influence the
customers to act in other words any copy
that encourages the recipient to act
immediately and the response from the
reader are measurable another type of
copyrighting is Public Relation
copyrighting in Public Relation
copyrighting you write newsworthy things
to catch your audience attention and
gain their trust it helps you quickly
earn an audience with credible sources
and as a result your business can
promote its product and services more
effectively whenever you search on
Google you see some ads at the top of
the search results that are also made up
using copyrighting following that next
we have ADD copyrighting this type of
copyrighting is used to create effective
ads generally it's used in Facebook and
Google ads now we reached the second
last type of copyrighting in the list
which is email copyrighting as you
understood by the name all the copy that
we use in emails are email copyrighting
it includes a good subject line nice
preview text an intro sentence for the
body of your email and a strong call to
action now let's discuss our last type
which is brand copyrighting brand
recognition and connecting with customer
begin with communication in what your
brand represents your brand image can be
conveyed through writing it can be in
the form of logo a song or a phrase to
create brand copy you have to think
about your customers first with this we
have come to the end of this
copyrighting types list before jumping
into the next topic I have a task for
you just pause this video and in the
comment box type your favorite type of
copyrighting I hope you are done with
the comment let's move forward to our
next topic which is difference between
copyright writing and content writing
firstly let's discuss the difference
based on the overall goal copywriting is
a type of writing aimed at selling a
brand on the other hand content writing
is all about building a perception in
consumer's mind the next difference is
based on the length of the content a
copywriter typically writes short form
of copy and a Content writer writes long
form of Copy Text written by copywriter
is brief and engaging content writer
often have to write more in-depth
content explaining a process or topic
now what's the difference when it comes
to a role in a company a copywriter is
someone whose primary role is to create
copy and a Content writer often does
more than just write it may be a writer
blogger executive or anyone else lastly
let's discuss the difference based on
SEO a good copywriter understand SEO but
when it comes to a good content writer
they should know about the advanced SEO
now let's explore some of the helpful
tools for a copywriter copy AI it's an
AI tool and the greatest thing about
this tool is it's very simple to use you
can generate Instagram caption product
description and even product value
proposition by just providing a few
words it's a paid tool but it has a 7
days free trial the next tool that we
have is grammarly grammarly is a free
online tool that finds mistakes in your
writing and suggests improvements as you
write grammarly will underline any
mistake you have made and offer
suggestions on how to fix them
additionally it has a plagarism Checker
and a punctuation checker however for
additional features you need to go with
grammarly premium word tune with the
help of grammar you can fix your writing
mistakes but when it comes to rephrase
and rewarding your content without
sacrificing flow tone or meaning word
tune came into the picture hence the
combination of grammarly and word tune
is the best for the copywriter and it's
a paid tool but have a free plan for
beginers the last tool in our bucket is
Wordsmith if you rely on data in your
day-to-day decisions wormith is a
perfect for you it can be used for
everything from journalism to financial
reporting because it produces natural
sounding content simply create one
template and set up a few variables and
Wordsmith will generate multiple
alternative scripts for example you can
write chatbot scripts for responding to
various complex customer requests now
comes the most interesting and the last
topic of our session the average salary
of a copywriter several factors
determine the income a person can expect
including experience the size of your
company your location and your industry
copywriters are the brain behind
advertisements explaining what the
product does and why people should buy
it they are also responsible for shaping
the Brand's identity and tone of voice
copy riters are a valuable resources for
businesses as they are responsible for
writing the first impression customers
get of a company a copywriters earns
approximately 3 lakh 64,000 perom in
India and in the US HEI can earn roughly
$53,000 and when it comes to a senior
copywriter the average salary in India
is 5 lak 86,000 perom and in the US HEI
can roughly earn
$78,000 per year content marketing is
becoming a key player in the digital
marketing domain if you are looking to
grab a successful career in content
marketing but not limited to content
marketing simply learn has got you
covered with wide range of topnotch
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands-on experience in
tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner Sam rush and there is a huge
list on the board however one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
this course find the course Link in the
description box in most organiz ation
the people who are doing search engine
optimization have been doing it for a
while and I can tell you cuz I've been
doing it for a while that in the old
days it was mostly technical with a
little bit of content sprinkled in so
for argument like let's say 8020 80% of
what an SEO needed to learn how to do
had to De with you you know your
metatags your metadata you know uh CMS
systems and blah blah blah blah blah and
oh by the way yeah you needed some
content on the page
well here we are a long time past that
and if this you you you you look through
this slide here for example uh this is
the latest guidance from
Google on the kind of content they
want and if you look through the list
here most of the items on it aren't
Technical and frankly most of it is
content and if you think about it what
this means is is that the job
description for SEO has changed
dramatically particularly beginning with
the panda update but then including the
uh penguin update and then hummingbird
and pardon me more and more and more
seos had better be interacting with the
people who are
creating quality content engaging
content credible qu
content um useful content it's not
enough just to put keywords in the right
places anymore on pretty thin content
that won't get you where you want to go
so
again different uh paths maybe the same
direction but the folks in content
marketing and the folks in SEO frankly
need each other and they may or may not
recognize it in your organization but
you know it's a starting point this is a
conversation you you probably need to
have content marketing is
complex it often overlaps with other
element elements of uh
marketing uh the the most typical
overlaps are with social media marketing
and
SEO and uh there probably already
are in your organization those kind of
groups the seos may be
on one floor and uh the social media
marketing people may be in a different
building you know
whatever but the new success formula say
we got to get all those folks to the
same table now we may have to do it
virtually we may have to use you know
webinars in order to hold those kind of
meetings who
knows but the point is is that uh you
know the world is Shifting and
organizational structures need to shift
with it and again you know that's not
something you can change
tomorrow but that is something that will
evolve over time and for what it's worth
it turns out that let's just say uh the
people who were in
SEO uh they may or may not admitted at
first but they absolutely need to work
with the people in content
marketing why because basically after
Panda and Penguin the rules
shifted and it's less about your title
tag and it's most mostly focused now on
the quality of your content and whether
that content is link worthy which means
it's really compelling content it's
remarkable content that's content that's
going to get people to link to it
because wow
that's you know and that's not
necessarily part of the skill set that
was required to be a successful SEO 5
years ago or 10 years
ago so again you got to get these folks
to the table they've got to work
together you know and um and again that
means the organizational structure
probably needs to
shift and the same is true with the
social media marketing folks you know
they went out and their initial goals
and objectives were you know get lots of
likes you know get lots of fans uh get
lots of views gets lots of Twitter
followers why because that seemed to be
the metric that the platform gave
us and so we used it to measure success
well it turns out none of those measures
actually measure real success because
they're focused on being successful on
the
platform boy I have lots of fans as
opposed to being successful in business
wow that generated lots of leads and
sales so there is a real real
discrepancy between let's just say the
center of
gravity okay it's not Facebook you're
not going to make uh a lot of money on
Facebook you know it's just not set up
to do
business you got to get those folks that
you've engaged in Facebook to your
website where they can buy
something and that's a you know radical
shift for all the folks who uh are in
social media marketing to say wait wait
time out
but that's not what I was told a couple
years ago and the answer is that's
correct what we've learned over time is
that being engaging is
useful if it's harnessed to a benefit
and I'll tell you in most organizations
the social media marketing people are
under
Cloud because they aren't delivering
business
benefit and they too need to learn to
work with the content marketing people
in order to do that and in some cases
they may not be creating the right kind
of
content that actually generates leads
and sales as opposed to you know is
inexpensive to create to get my next fan
or my next Twitter
follower so the key metrics here are no
longer how many likes or comments or
shares did you get that's
nice
but how many sales leads did you
generate what percentage of those
converted into
sales that's a radical change but again
it helps when the social media marketing
people are at the table with the content
marketing people there is a difference
between content strategy and content
marketing where content strategy focus
on the actual content content marketing
focuses on the outcome welcome content
strategy is about the management and
creation of the media the tools you are
using the resources you have available
what are the types of content you will
be
creating where content marketing is all
about the customer who are you targeting
with the content how well do you know
this person and most important of all
what is the expected business outcome
are you creating and sharing content to
build brand awareness or are you aiming
to increase
Revenue more generic content marketing
questions are how it fits within your
overall digital marketing strategy what
does your content calendar look like and
also by sharing your content are you
exposed to risk in any way does your
content work for every
Market content creation
framework a good way to start putting
together your content marketing strategy
is by creating your content marketing
framework it enables you to map out the
required content along the customer
buying Journey while considering the
impact it has on your online presence
your social media your website and your
sales between these two areas the
customer journey and your overall
digital marketing approach you have the
three types of content you need to focus
on link content conversion content and
Authority content link content is
content that drives traffic from the
internet and from your social media to
your website this is content that is
created with the goal of attracting
quality backlinks for SEO purposes
conversion content is content that
drives web visitors to the next stage in
the buying cycle through call to actions
or ctas this is the content that is
created with the goal to convince
prospects that they should buy from you
Authority content drives web visitors to
sales through call to actions and drives
repeat traffic to your website this is
content that is created to build a
community of people that trust you and
see you as the expert in your field this
is a useful structure to organize your
content and it keeps your focus on the
customer needs and the impact on your
overall digital marketing objectives
each type of content has different
requirements link content needs to be
high quality and often based on Research
so other websites can refer to it it's
all geared towards generating high
quality backlinks to your website which
Google Sees as very important for your
search ranking make this content fail
prooof repurpose it and promote it like
crazy conversion content is based on
helping the customer to go through the
buying cycle these will only work if you
understand what they need and they that
your content clearly articulates that
you can help them solve their problem
but on top of that it is vital in this
stage that your content gives them the
option to move to the next stage through
very clear and compelling call to
actions and Authority content is a
logical follow-up from your link content
it is content that confirms you are an
expert in your field it helps you to
build trust as long as you are truthful
transparent and show integrity and done
continuously and consistently it helps
you to deepen the relationship with your
prospects and your clients content
marketing strategy there are various
steps in developing your content
marketing strategy the obvious thing of
course is to start with setting your
objectives but Additionally you need to
do a number of things create customer
personas create listening outposts write
your Brand Story develop your channel
strategy create create your content
marketing Playbook measure your content
marketing and establish your content
marketing Roi let's look at these
elements of your content marketing
strategy in a bit more detail customer
personas a vital step in your content
marketing strategy is creating customer
personas this is a concept that comes
from the user interface and design World
in a customer Persona you look at things
like demographic characteristics six
like age and gender but it is important
to add to this what their pain points
are what is their Affinity with
technology where do they hang out online
and what are their interests and their
Hobbies once you completed your customer
personas print them out and put them on
the wall in your office and make sure
you add them to your briefing document
when you ask your agency to create a new
campaign HubSpot has a great free tool
to create customer personas
by asking a set of questions it will put
it in a format for you that you can
share and print and you can tailor it to
your own requirements and add your own
sections it includes things like
education social networks they use
preferred method of communication tools
they need to do their job goals and
objectives challenges and how they gain
knowledge establish listening post an
important part of your content marketing
strategy is to listen to what people are
talking about online you can find out
what they think about your brand the
topics they talk about and if there are
any issues it is also great to listen
online to find good content you could
share you don't have to share just your
own content there's nothing wrong with
sharing relevant content from others
obviously when I say listening online I
mean this in the widest sense watching
videos reading articles articles or
blogs looking at photos or infographics
or literally listening to podcasts here
are a few tools you can use to listen
feedle is a reader app on which you can
listen to Live RSS feeds Google Alerts
and talk Walker are tools that will send
you a notification for certain terms
that you have set you can use Google
Trends to find out search trends for
keywords your Brand's story The next
thing you need to work out for your
content marketing strategy is your Brand
Story what is your mission your vision
your values what is the story of your
company your CEO remember people want to
listen and share
stories when I search for IKEA on Google
you get an understanding of what I mean
stories about the history of the company
the founder of the company the way they
work the employees what makes them
unique and the more more twists turns
and uncertainties in these stories the
more people will love
them and it gets even better if you can
show them how you overcame obstacles and
bumps in the road this will increase
your credibility a good example of this
is Elon Musk from Tesla he came from a
very simple background but kept on
following his beliefs even when he was
nearly bankrupt he kept on going and
look where he is now an important
element of defining your content
marketing strategy is understanding of
what kind of brand you are the type of
brand you are determines the type of
social media you will get with your
content if you are a basic brand you
won't get many people to talk about you
let alone comment on your social media
posts you're just fulfilling a basic
need the only way these Brands can get
engagement on social media is to turn
themselves into a funny brand like Blend
Tech blenders who launched the will it
blend campaign if you are a functional
brand you will have customers who ask
questions about how to use your product
you need to respond to that by offering
content in which you answer their
questions exciting Brands don't have a
problem to get social media engagement
with their content they have thousands
of fans who love to talk about the brand
Harley-Davidson is a classic example
these Brands need to keep on posting
amazing content that become almost like
collector items for their
fans finally vital brands are for the
greater benefit of mankind Greenpeace
World Wildlife Fund UNICEF they have no
problem in getting engagement and
discussions but they should be very
alert on what people are talking about
and try to find influences that can help
them spread their cause
so think about this when you start
putting your content marketing strategy
together it will guide you on the type
of content and campaigns you should
create and the types of calls to action
you should
set social channel strategy before
you're going to decide on the type of
content you're going to create it makes
sense to agree on the social media
channels you are going to use in the
listening stage you have learned on
which channels your clients hang out so
now you're going to make sure you are
there as well you're going to
synchronize The Branding the key
messages and the campaigns to grow your
followers on these channels you need to
make sure you understand the latest
features and Trends on these social
channels it is also good to do a Content
Gap analysis what type of content do you
already have for each Channel and where
are the gaps so you know what type of
content you need to create here is a
useful template you can use for this it
shows you the channels the structure the
tone of voice for each Channel and the
desired action the gaps will give you an
indication of the work you need to do to
make sure you have a coherent content
marketing
strategy content marketing
Playbook so now you are in a position to
decide on the type of content you're
going to create here is a list
structured by the three types of content
we saw earlier link conversion and
Authority content link content and
Authority content can be fairly similar
it's more on the promotion side where
they differ but the conversion content
needs to be organized along the customer
Journey from awareness to evaluation to
purchase we call this the marketing
Playbook you need to create your own by
selecting the right content for the
right
stage measuring content marketing
efforts you can measure the traffic you
get through your content you can measure
the engagement you get and you can
measure the sentiments whether you are
targeting consumers or businesses the
metrics are the same but the priorities
May differ today lead generation is seen
as the number one kpi when it comes to
measuring the success of your content
marketing closely followed by traffic
generation to your website these metrics
show how your content marketing efforts
are succeeding but you need to go a
level deeper to discover what specific
content campaigns channels and efforts
are most effective in driving value and
in the end whether you are in b2c or B2B
it comes down to measuring the ROI of
your content marketing how much money
did you earn from your content Marketing
in relation to the cost you incurred in
creating and distributing it the things
that can improve your Roi are quality of
your leads sales web traffic engagement
SEO success and brand exposure and
remember improved Roi is not just based
on more sales it can also be based on
lowering cost planning your content
marketing strategy planning your content
marketing strategy is very important
there are so many things you need to
take into consideration if you don't put
some structure into this you may lose
control it is best to create your
content marketing process guide in this
guide you specify how you create and
manage your content how you optimize and
curate how you listen and engage in
conversations and how you measure your
content marketing besides this there is
the Tactical stuff like roles and
responsibilities what are the style and
writing guidelines and similar what are
the guidelines for posting and
Publishing and make sure you communicate
the process guide to the relevant people
in your organization you may want to put
a training together to to the people who
will work with this on a daily basis a
vital part of your process guide is the
content marketing calendar it's the
calendar that contains your content
production and publication schedule
there are many templates and tools for
this on the internet my favorite ones
are trello.com and Google Calendar the
most important part of it is that it is
a collaborative tool so you can schedule
the calendar with your colleagues or
with your client you can give people
viewing or editing access you can use
color codes for the different types of
content or for the different channels
becoming a Content marketing company to
give you a framework on how to organize
your content marketing strategy in your
company you can look at the content
marketing Institute four business models
for Content
marketing they can be mapped in a
quadrant with strategic importance on
one AIS and internal external focus on
the other your you're a player when your
content marketing strategy is focused on
supporting teams within the organization
like your product marketing or marketing
communication teams most companies start
their content marketing like this it's
seen as a contributor you're a performer
when your content marketing is seen as a
center of excellence in your
organization it has an external Focus
where audience segmentation is key it
can be seen as a support function to
other parts in the organization you're a
processor when you centralize certain
content functions but not the actual
creation of it your corporate team may
create a Content campaigns with the
corporate guidelines where your local
teams are responsible for local content
creation to execute a campaign and
you're a platform when you approach your
content marketing as a strategic
business within your business often this
is done on a corporate level and this is
is separate from local content marketing
initiatives so you need to understand
where you are today and have a vision of
where you want to go right out of the
gate let's start talking about knowing
your audience okay so content is all
about writing for a particular audience
so it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect
demographics of your target audience
based on who's coming to your website so
you can get that data in Google
analytics under audience email
subscribers I mean who is subscribing to
your emails who do you already have in
your email database and you can look at
social media I mean you look at Facebook
you can look at the people who are
already connected to you okay these are
just some three three of many examples
you could be doing to gather data on
your audience okay you have to know who
your audience is before you start
writing you know for a successful
content marketing strategy you really
just need to know your audience and
basically you're going to segment them
based on their interest so that content
is going to be catered to that audience
okay so if it's an audience that likes a
specific you know product uh that you
offer or feature that's part of that
product that you offer then that's the
segment you're going to be writing about
so you need to collect your data on your
audience ahead of time then you're going
to segment that audience okay so you're
not going to write content for everyone
because the shoe doesn't necessarily fit
for everyone okay the shoe has to fit
for specific foot and in this case we're
talking about an audience we need to be
able to segment our audience out and you
could certainly segment them out by age
by gender by education level by income
by interest I mean these are just some
of the examples again it could be new
returning or new users versus returning
users it could be users who have
purchased from you in the past versus
users who haven't purchased from you in
the past it could certainly be an age
range it could be even going further on
interest level or combination there of
okay so for example you can get that
demographic information using Google
Analytics
just got to go in analytics under
audience under demographics you're going
to see age and it's age is broken out by
age range and you're going to see gender
so you're going to see a breakdown of
gender and use that to your advantage so
if you're going to you know write some
content and you know 99% of your traffic
is female the age of 18 to 24 then you
know that content be catered accordingly
so you could certainly go to Facebook
pages insights and get some really good
demographic data there cuz Facebook is
all about demographics okay so you could
see exactly you know how many fans you
have broken out by men versus women and
then you could see again same thing as
Google analytics you could see an age
range breakout you can use Twitter
analytics I mean Twitter has share some
really good insights into education
level so you know if you're dealing with
you know highly sophisticated people who
have master's degrees or even higher or
let's just say even on LinkedIn you know
that majority of the people you're
trying to Target are SE Lev meaning
CEOs or CFOs or CMOS You Know Chief
marketing officers or chief executive
officers then you're going to cater your
message a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high range managers or even VPS so use
your audience information you collect on
these various platforms to your
advantage okay so let's jump into number
two we want to create high quality
content now I know this sounds like a
given but and I say but heavily you
there's not a lot of high quality
content out there on the internet so
separate yourself first and foremost
always always always create high quality
content it's going to result in a lot of
things are going to benefit you you know
one you're going to come across as you
know somebody who knows what they're
talking about and that's going to help
increase your brand awareness okay when
you increase your brand awareness people
know about you so it's likely going to
increase traffic to your website or if
you're on social media you know if you
produce good high quality content people
are going to share that content okay so
from an SEO perspective it can improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality content you know and it's really
focused in on a specific topic or or a
certain set of core words keywords then
you're going to rank improves website
dwell time meaning hey you get good
content people are going to hang around
to see what else you have to offer okay
so it's no secret that you know good
content you usually leads to you know
quality engagement and then certainly
last but not least you can gain a lot of
leads here meaning hey some likes what
you have to say whether it's a video or
blog post or or infographic you know
people are going to become more
interested more engaged spend more time
and that's all going to funnel through
to somebody taking that next step in the
funnel and becoming more interested in
your service or even purchasing one of
your products so creating high quality
content involves brainstorming topics
and terms you know you got to do The
Upfront work due diligence is at work
here so brainstorm some topics use a
keyword research tool to gather results
so if you have a topic you know one of
the benefits of quality content is
rankings go to Google's Keyword Planner
understand how much quality and and
understand how much competition each
keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in Google's Keyword Planner or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention write a nice
headline that's going to grab their
attention Okay so give valuable content
to your readers and add resources from
well-known sites so if you you do borrow
say a data point from another source
then you know site that Source you also
want to create engaging in
thought-provoking content get somebody
to think I mean people are going to
raage your content because they not they
don't know the subject matter their
interest in the subject matter and they
want to be able to spend the time taking
something away from that content follow
a logical structure and use relevant
images I can't stress this one enough
you know just throw things on a web page
you know put some structure to it may
you have to break it out if you feel
like you have too much content there's
no harm in breaking it into part one
versus part two get people uh tease them
a bit get them to come back and read
part two okay use different content
forms in case somebody's interested
maybe they want to capture some data you
know prefer short paragraphs to make the
content readable remember if you're
talking to sea level folks you know
maybe you don't have to dummy down the
content so to speak but if you're
dealing with you know folks or people
that are right out of high school or
still in high school then adjust your
content and format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done I mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change it's a medium
that is dynamic okay so if a data
Point's changed go back in and update
that data point and then let people know
about it because they may want to come
back and and you know check in to see
how much that data Point's changed so
these are all you know good takeaways
for creating high quality content there
some other things that you should be
aware of you know grammatical mistakes
you know you need to avoid those there's
no reason for grammatical mistakes
today's technology doesn't allow for it
and Hey listen we all have friends we
have colleagues my desk is sitting next
to a colleague who's more than happy to
read something before it gets published
so take advantage of the resources you
have available no reason for it cuz if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is okay so creating content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is is
it fulfilling their requirements you
don't know be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points and then just don't put words on
a web page you know so break up that
content with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing cont
content and then give more information
to your audience and we say prefer to
give more information meaning hey going
back to the content I was saying about
breaking it up organizing it if you have
more information you don't withhold it
have them come back and read a secondary
blog post or secondary piece that
supports the original now we want to
move from high quality content to
running AB test AB test so important why
because with AB split test testing you
can increase your conversion rates okay
so four elements to test in your content
marketing strategy so if you have
content say a Blog and you're testing
that blog you know test out the images
test out the forms do you have a long
form or short form you know test out the
content length you can have a variation
that is a lot shorter than the original
does that increase or decrease bounce
rates play around with call to actions
you know call to actions do do matter
you know do you want to use a softer
call to action a softer tone or do you
want to use something very direct and
strong you know test call to actions to
see what's going to get people to move
closer through the closer to purchasing
and through that funnel so AB testing to
me is something that should be naturally
done with Google optimize it's free so
with images you know you could test a
lot of different variations of images
anything from people to you know
outlandish imagery to just something
very stock and neutral but just make
sure that those images are relevant to
the post you know test the length of
that content you know again if you know
that your average time on page is very
low you know don't write something very
long write something that you think is
going to stick with that time of page
but on your ab test create something
maybe a little longer if it's engaging
enough maybe somebody's going to stay a
little bit longer on the page so you
know create a variation it's going to
play with that length okay so use
analytics to your advantage to figure
out as a baseline what amount of content
is getting people to stay on the page
then see if you could push the envelope
one way or the other okay improving the
page with sign up forms really what you
want to do is create a userfriendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to Facebook or Google so if
they're creating an account they can
traing account via Google or Facebook or
you know don't put too many forms on the
page and then on those ctas as I
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color I mean I
test color all the time Believe It or
Not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the Middle East or
the Far East Asia you know color schemes
and what you say matters and it changes
versus say you know Europe or the West
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or tone or
placement and things of that nature so
you want to conduct a competitor
analysis so we're talking about creating
high quality content testing that
content you know brainstorming some
topics you know looking at your audience
you're doing all this work you might as
well take the next step and figure out
what it is your competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitor's top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so really what we're trying to
do here is improve our conversion rates
so what are your competitors doing what
are their baselines we can maybe up that
Annie I mean that data is also available
in Google analytics so you can look at
benchmarking reports in Google analytics
to get some form or fashion you can also
go to Facebook and look at your
competitors Facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of Engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include Facebook as well or maybe even
LinkedIn so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag in The Meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
SEO platform like search uh sem rush or
MZ or something like that that's going
to allow you to get some good Insight on
competitor information so keep in mind
there are SEO platforms that will give
you information on your competitors and
that's what these SEO platforms are good
for so number five moving on choose a
suitable content format so now we've
done all this homework we know what we
want to say we know who we want to say
it to we're ready to do some testing but
we need to find a format because it's
not always about a web page per se
meaning content on a web page or not
always about a blog post with content in
that blog post okay we need to decide
the type of content that's going to fit
what we're trying to say so again you
can go the traditional route with just
posting a blog post and there nothing
wrong with that because with a blog post
you can incorporate video and imagery
you can also go a more harder route when
I say harder more I's Say official route
with an ebook or case study something
that a user is going to be able to take
away with maybe download okay something
more official um something more indepth
something with a harder stamp on it so
that that shows individuals that you've
taken the time you've done this homework
you've done this research you've done
some really indepth analysis and now the
proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an ebook now if you're into
talking like I am then you could
certainly do a podcast and podcasts are
always popular depending on the topic so
you got to be aware of the topic now
videos are always always a good option
you got the likes of video and videoo
and YouTube and some other you know
video platforms out there that allow you
the ability to get found very quickly
especially with the likes of YouTube you
know people use YouTube before they go
on to purchasing a product so think
about that so if you're trying to get
somebody if you're trying to sway an
audience to move from being a brand
awareness and a loyal you know customer
to taking the next step okay to
purchasing more or purchasing for the
first time and so videos kind of help
convey that now if you're trying to
convey a lot of different points then an
infographic might be your best option
instead of having to write out all those
points you try using an infographic to
convey those points visually now again
with blog post it should have valuable
content that can be shared by your
website V visitors on social so that's
the key make sure you have those
sharable social icons now with ebooks it
should have longer in-depth content so
and it shouldn't be published frequently
so maybe if this is something you're
doing annually then ebook could be the
format with a case study what you should
have a customer story that succeeded in
and you solving that customer's problem
so the case study is always there for
you know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in a more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
Reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture hey
everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also sharable on blog posts in pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a Content management system
that's going to work for you so you want
to be able to choose something where you
can plan appropriately produce manage
publish and measure results all in one
place there are plenty of content
Management Systems out there that will
help you do all of those things Okay so
some examples are WordPress HubSpot
binder I mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know WordPress
is the way to go if you're into building
at landing pages that you want to you
know share you know hotspot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven Target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
know maybe get them to you know fill out
a survey via email based on that podcast
or if you create a podcast about some
data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
can certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog post you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly you know you can
collect emails and send out those emails
with you know certain information or
what you should be doing is targeting
and segmenting your emails just like you
are your content so if you're producing
content for a certain audience then make
sure that particular audience gets that
same email now some of the email content
that you could share with your tarting
audience are newsletters okay seasonal
emails promotional emails automated
messaging and what we mean by automated
messaging hey if somebody just purchased
from you send them a thank you email
maybe follow up a couple days later with
another email with a survey or what you
could do is if you know who your loyal
customers are you target them with a
promotional email so there's lots of
ways to slice and dice content via email
okay just make sure you know your target
audience is there's lots of things you
can do in email again you can complement
lots of different formats with an email
as I mentioned before with a podcast
blog post so keep all that in mind email
is a good way to communicate with your
audience okay the last point we want to
make here is use native ads okay so we
talk about Native ads it's one of the
smartest ways to connect your audience
with your brand so for example this is a
native ad on BuzzFeed okay it's about 15
bands that probably wouldn't exist
without Leed Zeppelin okay so for you
folks out there that don't know who lead
Zeppelin is a rock group from the 70s
late 60s 7s okay disbanded in 80 81 82
early 80s okay but you know people grew
up like myself listening to Le Zeppelin
okay so you could see the headline here
15 bands that probably w't exist without
Le Zeppelin you know I'm interested in
who those bands might be even if you
don't know who lead Zeppelin is okay you
might be in quisitive to say okay who is
this lead Zeppelin group and what are
these 15 bands the key here here is not
necessarily the headline or lead
Zeppelin per se but it's a native ad and
it's sitting next to content talking
about music okay so according to Forbes
online audiences are 25% more likely to
look at a native ad than add a banner
and so that native ad in this case we're
talking about music needs to be sitting
or comped alongside content talking
about in this case music you know would
help if it was rock music just music in
general might get enough to get Peak
people's interest okay so if you're
going to create content you know align
that content with something that's you
know naturally going to fit and that's
why we call them native ads CU they're
native to the content that they're
associated with so finally after all
that's said and done when all you've
done is create good content follow up V
emails targeting your audience and
associating that content with you know
content natively then you can always
measure your content performance so my
favorite part of it all you going to
analytics going to Facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content's performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is
associating the content with kpis that's
really the key so measuring the right
metric can help you understand whether
your content is engaging or not so again
measuring the right metrix okay so when
we're talking about a video you're not
necessar going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and Pags bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that you're
aligning the right metric with the right
asset so for example if you have a case
study in ebook you want to make sure
that you're measuring how many downloads
the ebook or the case stud received
again with the video you want to measure
video views now if you're packaging up
emails and sending them out to your
target audience you want to make sure
you look at open rates and click rates
okay so a lot of things you can be
looking at so make sure you choose the
right metric is there's hundreds and
hundreds of metrics to choose from so
just be aware all the different metrics
that are available you know if you're in
it for search okay how much traffic
getting from search where are you
ranking so there a lot of things you
need to think about so think about the
content that you're producing and think
about how you want to be able to measure
that content so let's go back over our
checklist here so what you could do is
create an editorial calendar in fact I
would highly suggest you create an
editorial calendar in order to keep
track of all the content you've done
over period of time are you making your
content worth reading that means are you
checking the results of that content
what we just went over measuring the
content is it worth reading have a
column set up in that editorial calendar
you know performing or not performing if
it's not performing don't do it again
okay curate your content okay you always
want to you know make sure you're
reusing or using or adding to the
content that you've created guest post
on influen IAL blogger websites you want
to add statistics numbers and quotes to
your content make it engaging make it
look like you've done your homework you
can share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
SlideShare now you can share it on all
social media platforms I'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a Blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you could send out an email with
a survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
Facebook you know leverage the feedback
you get from Facebook in the form of a
testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means SEO so
make sure you do your D diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create person for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
Right audience whether that be young
middle-aged or older are you choosing
the right type of content okay you'll
know based on the results okay you want
to add H1 and H2 tags on your web pages
why because when we're talking about
content we're talking about organizing
the content and H1 and H2S help you or
organize the content appropriately
customize the metadata metadata is title
tag and meta tag descriptions and even
all tags okay all of that is for search
so you want your content to show up in
search whether that's video infographic
or blog post all of it can be shown in
search results so make sure you write a
good title and make sure you write a
good meta description because that's
what people are going to see when they
search so you want to create a detailed
summary and title and again that goes
along with the title tag and meta
description and then you want to make it
easy for the audience to ask questions
and comment on your blog so don't be
afraid like I'm going to do right now in
this video is if I'm missing anything
from this checklist feel free to comment
hey I've written my fear share content
but I could be talking to an audience
that is just as qualified as I am and
they may have some tips so feel free to
comment underneath this video now don't
be afraid to ask just like I just did
people are always willing to provide
constructive feedback so don't be afraid
to ask for it and make it easy so to me
every blog post needs to have some form
of a comment box because blog posts are
out there to solicit engagement
RI this may not be the term that is
bandied about inside your organization
it's certainly not a term that is bendi
about in the
industry but it's actually the one that
you want to use so let me
explain what is in it for you to measure
this this actually begins to position
you not as the company's next CMO it may
position you as the company's next
CEO because guess what the CFO is not
the top of the food
chain and the CFO has generally been
asking for the wrong thing for
years this is the right thing to
demonstrate this is the calculation you
want to
do this puts you in a powerful
position first of all you shift the
conversation you basically put yourself
in a position of
convincing generally it's the
CFO that you understand Finance as well
as he or she
does and you know most CFOs aren't
expecting that from somebody in
marketing you know you know they tend to
look down on us we're we're merely the
expense you know that they have to
deduct somewhere along the way in their
financial
calculations okay fine but here's the
deal Roi is the wrong metric the CFO may
ask for it because the CFO is used to
asking for it for other kinds of things
like Capital
expenditures if you're going to do a
capital expenditure like building a new
Factory or a plant or you're going to
stock a lot of inventory someplace
that's a capital expenditure or what is
known as cap X and trust me if you are a
publicly traded company some investor
out there some industry analyst is going
to want to know about your capex it's
something you're going to have to report
on a quarterly basis so trust me the CFO
is focused on
it but that kind of money is tied up up
when you make that kind of investment
it's generally a long-term one and you
may depreciate it but you know what
that's why everyone's sort of focused on
it it turns out marketing is not a
capital
expenditure marketing is an expense you
generally expense it over the course of
a quarter you know we spent some money
this month on who knows advertising
content marketing you f in the
blank and if it is an operational
expenditure then it is called
opx and if you want to measure the
impact of what you're doing in
marketing you know you end up using a
very different formula than your CFO has
been asking for for years but here's the
deal when you look across the table and
say actually you're asking for the wrong
thing what you really want is RI not
Roi um and yeah I do know how to
calculate calate that a return on
marketing investment is basically the
incremental Revenue that you can
attribute to your marketing so you know
we've been measuring goals or micro
goals and you can measure those in
Revenue because you know uh what the
lead is that you brought in and what
it's worth and you know what the sales
uh you brought in and what they're worth
or you you certainly know what
percentage of those leads tend to
convert to sales and therefore you you
got a uh a figure that what your sales
pipeline may be valued at guess what you
can calculate that and then here's the
magic you go beyond
Revenue a lot of people would stop there
and say wow that's an impressive thing
I've never reported Revenue before
aren't I a hero now but if you take the
next step and you say an all so I know
what our contribution margin is a lot of
people will call that your profit margin
in other words uh when you raise revenue
there's still a cost of goods sold you
know takes some money to manufacture
your product or it takes some money um
you know that you for the people you
have to uh pay to deliver your
service and when you're all done paying
uh you know the cost of goods sold
what's left is your
profit and that is a percentage of your
Revenue
and if you multiply the revenue that you
brought in times the profit margin so
some percentage of that is going to turn
into profit and then you subtract what
you
spent on your content marketing
campaign and divide by what you spent on
your content marketing
campaign you come up with a number it's
your
RI
and let me give you an example just to
sort of bring this home let's say for
example that you spent $100,000 on a
Content marketing
program and it delivered $500,000 in
incremental Revenue that you have been
able to track and say didn't come in
from outer space you know here's the
campaign we ran we generated this and oh
by the way the contribution margin for
that 500,000 in Revenue was let's say
60% in other words it took about 40% to
cover the cost of good sold but the
profits on top of that were 60% where
does that number come from it's a
mythical number but you know it's going
to vary in different organizations I'm
just using it here to teach you the
math but I'm going to measure my results
by taking that 500,000 multiplying by
60% because I want to get to the profit
number
and then I'm going to subtract the
100,000 that I spent and divide by the
100,000 and I get the number
two and you're going to say I've never
heard this number before and the answer
is neither has your
CFO but here's what it
means for every dollar that you spent on
content marketing you generated
$2 in
profit not Revenue you generated $5 in
Revenue you generated
$2 in
profit now do you want to do a little
more content marketing next quarter let
me tell you anything that is a positive
number is a good result if you can get
anything north of One content marketing
is becoming a key player in the digital
marketing domain if you are looking to
grab a successful career in content
marketing but not limited to content
marketing simply learn has got you
covered with wide range of topnotch
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands-on experience in
tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner Sam rush and there is a huge
list on the board
however one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course find
the course Link in the description
box today in an era of mobile devices
robots and social media content creation
is the most effective inbound marketing
strategy nearly 40% of marketers say
content marketing is essential to their
marketing strategy and 81% say their
company views content as a business
strategy original and high quality
content can help you companies stand out
and attract new customers and help your
business grow on that note welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel today we
are here with a fantastic video on chat
GPD for Content creation which will help
you create some compelling content on
your desired topics but before we begin
are you aiming to get certified as a
digital marketer and want to build your
career in digital marketing well in that
case you can check the professional
digital marketing course by simply learn
which will open the doors for the best
career opportunities to find the details
of the professional digital marketing
course check the link in the description
box below it could be an ideal solution
to help you build career in the right
direction and if you haven't subscribed
already please subscribe to our Channel
simply learn and hit that Bell icon to
never miss an update from us but before
we get started guys I have a question
for you is CH GPT an application and is
it available on Android well let us know
the answer in the comments below so let
us understand what is chat GPT here now
content creation can be of any type such
as blogs podcast videos graphics and so
on but how do you create highquality
content with a few minutes it not be
worried when we have chat GPT now even
though there are numerous AI writing
tools for Content creation chat GPT
stands out from the crowd due to its
faster response rate ease of use
increased productivity support for
multiple languages and other benefits
now let's try to understand what exactly
CH is and how to create content from it
now generally chat GPT is an open AI
trained and developed model that works
conversationally chat GPT is capable of
systematically resolving all bugs while
providing detailed explanation for each
step it takes so in simple words chat
GPT is a tool that creates content for
any query chat GPT stands out among all
the other achievements of open AI so let
us now move ahead and understand how
does chat GPT work now chat GPT uses
deep learning techniques to generate
human like text which is based on a
machine learning model derived from the
large language model class now it is
trained on a massive Text data sets from
the internet and learns patterns and
relationship between words and phrases
it responds to a question by selecting
the next word based on the context and
then repeats the process until a stop
condition is fulfilled so as a result
chat GPT can logically respond to your
queries and commands so let's see how to
create content in chat GPT now as we
already discussed content creation can
be of any type so for instance let's
take blog a Blog is an online general or
a website where a writer or a group of
writers share their views on an
individual subject now there are variety
of categories for writing a Blog so
let's pick one for chat GPD here so as
you can see we have navigated into chat
GPD and let us now ask a simple question
about food blogging now lately food
blogs are the most popular blogs that
everyone wants to write about so let's
find out what chat GPT has to say about
it now you can give any question to chat
GPT and it will answer so I'm just uh
writing a question here saying how to
start a foot blogging
carrier so as you can see it is
generating the answer for us uh wait for
it to
end well as you can see it is saying
that starting a foot block can be a fun
and rewarding way to sh Your Love of
food with others so it is showing us
some steps to get started in food
blogging career it is saying choose a
nishe choose a name and domain choose a
blogging platform create your blog
create high quality content and so on so
in this way chat GPT will automatically
generate the response for you based on
the questions that you are giving input
to it next we will see another question
on lifestyle blogs now with the world on
social media everyone wants to read more
about lifestyle especially of a famous
or a popular uh entity what habits they
adapt and what to let go of Etc so let's
explore this segment in chat GPT as well
and see what it will show the answer so
let's uh give the question as how to
start
lifestyle blogging in
India so it is giving the answer for us
guys so it is saying that starting a
lifestyle blog in IND can be a great way
to share your experiences and knowledge
with others who share similar interest
so here are some steps to help you get
started again it is giving some uh
important points for us in order to
start your lifestyle blogging career
like choose your nishe choose a name and
domain choosing a blogging platform
create your blog create high quality
content and so on beginners let me give
you a few facts and figures about blogs
before we dive into the topic did you
know that that there are more than 600
million blogs on the internet and every
day over 2 million blog posts are
published on all those blog posts that
are out there
77% of Internet users they read blog and
they leave about 77 million comments per
month on all these blog posts so it is a
massive um place where you can get
engagement and where you can get people
talking about the things that you're
writing about now people that include
visuals to their blogs they will see
that they get about
94% more views than those people that do
not add visuals to their blog
surprisingly Tumblr is the most used
blogging platform with over half a
billion blogs out there but there are 60
million blogs that are powered by
WordPress press also did you know that
blogs are the second most form of media
used in content marketing so lots about
blogging lots of facts they're out there
they're key they're relevant and this
blog is going to introduce you to how to
get started with a Blog now blogs have
been around for a very long time yeah do
you know what the name of the first blog
was and who created it was it a B C or D
well let me give you the answer Justin
Hall started link.net in
1994 as a student at a um at a college
becoming one of the first widely read
bloggers out there in the late 1990s the
first blogs were created primarily
serving as personal journals for small
groups of friends or for family now in
the early 2000s blogging tools and
service
became more widely available and it is
also when I got my first experience in
blogging when my son went on a um on a
gap year traveling in in Southeast Asia
and he shared his photos through the
internet on a uh on a Blog so he found
internet cafes during his journey and in
each Cafe he he started up his blog and
added a photo so that's how I could
follow his uh his trip so it makes it
became easier easier for people to start
to create and maintain their own blogs
in 2002 the term blog was coined and
became widely used to describe a website
that serves as an online journal or a
diary so in 2004 the political world
started to get an idea about the power
of blogs they emerged and played a role
in shaping public opinion influencing
selections 2005 to 2010 was the the big
growth of blogs and they started to gain
popularity and they came into sort of
the um into the more widely
uh discussible areas like photography
blogs and recipe blogs and then in the
2010 businesses got to see the power of
blogs and they started to use blogs as a
mainstream form of communication and for
other people as self-expression with
millions of blogs covering every
possible subject and serving a diverse
range of audiences so today blogging
continues to play a significant role in
the rise of social media and it has a
very big impact on the way people
communicate and consume information
online a fantastic tool to learn to find
out about what's happening in the world
what's find to find out what's happening
in particular niches that you're
interested in and a great way to start
sharing your your own opinion so what
will we be talking about we're going to
be talking about what is a Blog what
skills do you need for blogging why
actually should you create a blog what
are the types of blog posts that you can
create and I'm going to show you some
examples of those different types of
blog posts how do you create a blog and
I'm going to give you some blog writing
tips to close off with the uh on the
video today so let's get into it what is
a Blog now there are many different
definitions of a Blog yeah there a Blog
can be a personal blog it can be a
corporate blog it can be a news blog
yeah so a personal blog is where it's a
type of blog where individuals share
their thoughts their opinions their
experiences their um their stories on a
particular topic or a particular range
yeah these type of blogs are very easy
easy to set up and they don't cost a lot
of money but it's very much with a
personal Focus businesses they usually
have corporate blogs it's a type of blog
by created is by a company and um it can
be used for marketing it can be used for
Branding it can be used for
communication purposes for lead
generation usually they share company
news they share product updates or
industry Insight yep so it's also really
good to engage with customers and to get
in a dialogue with customers to build
relationships and to create um thought
expertise in a particular Niche the
third type of blog that you can see and
this definition of a blog is a news blog
is a type of blog that focuses on
reporting and analyzing current events
current news stories what's happening in
the world from a particular angle it
could be one journalist it could be a
group of journalists it could be a media
organization yeah and it can cover a
wide range of topics or it can focus on
a particular Niche like entertainment or
like technology so it can be used to
create different perspectives on new
stories or to supplement the traditional
new stories but if we're looking at the
plain definition of a Blog if you look
at all the blogs they work from the same
concept yeah a blog is a type of website
serving as an online journal or diary
and it consists of posts on a particular
topic or a particular theme yeah now a
Blog can be created by an individual or
by businesses and as say as I said
earlier they can serve different
purposes for personal or for business or
for news they're very easy to create
blogs and that makes them so powerful
then you can use Simple blogging
software there's lots of free tools
available and you can get started within
5 minutes they have lots of features
like commenting yes so um and by using
the commenting functions you can allow
engagement with your readers and you can
really build up a
community now you can find blogs on
specific Standalone websites like a Blog
website or you can find them on um
embedded within a corporate uh corporate
website you could even blog on social
media networks like LinkedIn or um or
Facebook and they often use a Content
management system yep to um to create a
blog to manage the blog and to add new
content new pages on your
blog blogging for me is the easiest way
to get started with social media yeah so
they played a significant role in the
growth of social media and it had
fundamentally changed the way businesses
communicated with um with their
customers yes so and and how people sort
of consume
information yes so blogs they have a
number of things in common yeah so if
you go to a Blog each blog you will see
a number of recurring things the first
thing of course that you see are the
blog posts they are the Articles or the
entries written or published on the
blogs and they can be in different
presentation formats yeah you can see it
in little thumbnails you can see it in
the headlines yeah um or you can see
just a scroll down of all the blog posts
but the blog posts are obviously the
core of each blog post blogs have
comments you can switch off the comments
if you want but most blogs they have
commenting and they are an important
part of a Blog because they allow you to
engage with the author yeah or that the
author can engage with their readers so
that gives a platform for discussion for
feedback and for interaction around the
blog yeah when you start blogging you
may have a you may build up a big
library of blogs of blog posts yeah so a
common feature on every blog is that
they have categories and tags yep and
you see them on the column on the right
on blog posts and that means that you
can easily access previous content so
you're not stuck to the main article but
you give people access to other content
through categories through tags or the
most popular post or the last five posts
blogs also have an about page what what
is this blog all about it provides
reader with information about the author
of The Blog yeah the purpose of the blog
the mission of the blog so some
background information good blogs also
have a search box yeah it's another way
where you can easily search for Content
yeah that has already been published on
the blog now a Blog without sharing
buttons yeah is like you're keeping it a
secret
so one of the powerful features of a
Blog is that you as the author can share
it on social media but you can also ask
your readers to share it on social media
by using the sharing buttons then there
is the archive section where it
organizes the post by month by year or
by category again making it easy to
access previous content and then many
blogs have a call to action yeah so that
is a button that encour encourages
readers to take a specific action like
subscribing to the blog or downloading
an ebook or signing up for a newsletter
yeah so it's very good tool to start
creating and building your
audience and on top of that you need to
think about the design and the
navigation of your blog is very
important and we talked about that in
our other blogging video um that we
posted a few weeks ago yes so those are
the common elements of a Blog so let's
dig a bit deeper we talked about yeah
how a Blog can be personal it can be for
business it can be news as long as it is
in a specific topic yes
so around that topic or theme you can
start sharing your thoughts sharing your
ideas your knowledge and you can express
yourself so most some of the most
important and in demand topics for blogs
are lifestyle yeah like topics like
Fashion Beauty Health Wellness travel
and food are very popular they have a
very wide appeal and that's very
personal relevance to readers as well
technology is a very hot topic yes so
the Fast Change of Technology U
Innovation technological developments
there's always something to write about
there's always news around
um technology yeah so that is a very hot
topic another topic is personal finance
people love to know more about how to
manage their P finances and blogs can be
a really good way to help the readers
and giving them tips in how to manage
their Finance um in a range of topics
from savings investing Deb management um
and
budgeting yeah there's blogs about
Business and Entrepreneurship they are
very popular from starting a new
business yeah to growing an existing one
how to relate to your customers there's
a huge demand for top for blogs around
the theme of business and business
support now there's news websites
there's news blogs around current events
that cover the latest news yeah they are
popular they can focus on a particular
area like what's it like politics or
technology or they can cover a more
broad range as well there's creative
blogs creative writing creative
literature writing yes so blogs that are
about creative writing and about
literature they can be a great source of
inspiration and then finally personal
development is a very big category in
blogs a very popular category yeah
personal development and
self-improvement like personal growth
self-care self-improvement they're
really popular and they are relevant to
people's daytoday life yeah so these are
some of the most popular blog posts and
the blog topics that people um that
people are interested in so for you
start looking into the topics if you
want to start blogging yeah and see if
you can pick a sort of a a a topic that
is within these uh within the these
categories so is blogging difficult do I
need a wide range of skills for blogging
well it's not too difficult but of
course people have lots of different
questions about blogging before they
start how do I start a blog how do I
come up with ideas for my blog content
how do I get traffic to my blog how
often should I publish on my blog post
how do I monitor ize my blog what should
I write about what should I include in
my blog post how do I write an exciting
headline how do I promote my blog on
social media how do I engage with my
readers how do I track the success of my
blog lots and lots of questions yeah and
of course to answer all these questions
you do need to have certain skills
before you start blogging so let's have
a look at those skills so to be
successful with a Blog and to
successfully start a blog there are some
skills that you need of course you can
work on those skills you can start
building up those skills but these are
the five topics that are playing an
important part of your blogging work
your blogging activity there's
writing there's search engine
optimization there's marketing
there's web design and there's social
media yeah so first you need to be able
to write you need to research you need
to write in a clear concise and engaging
manner yep and that is a skill in itself
and of course when you start blogging
you you may not have that much
experience but when you have been
blogging for 6 months to a year you will
see that it gets easier and
easier the next thing you need to do is
to be able to optimize your blog posts
for search for Google for Bing yeah so
that they those search engines will find
your blog posts when you publish them
yeah and a very important part of your
search engine optimization is to
identify the keywords that are relevant
for your business and relevant for your
blog and then you need to understand how
to use those keywords
effectively then of course you need to
Market your blog you need to grow an
audience you need to get people to
subscribe to your blog maybe to start
building an email uh list yeah so you
need to understand email marketing you
need to know online marketing to promote
your blog you need to know how to do
that you need to know where to do that
you may want to look at affiliate
marketing which means you can promote
other people's product on your blog and
you would get a um a small commission
for that yes so lots of marketing
activities that you need to look into to
actually to publish your blog and make
it become visible and make it become
popular now of course there is the web
design element for your blog as well and
those are skills that you need to have
there are very simple tools as you will
see later yeah that you can use to set
up your uh your blog there's free tools
that you can use there's more advanced
tools as well and as with many things
with the more advanced tools and the
premium tools that you use you get more
quality you get more options you get
often a better design yeah so that is
the balance that you need to strike
between hey how much do I want to do for
free and want to do simple uh compared
to do you want to invest some money and
do you want to have a more advanced um
website yes so that is the balance that
you need to do but you do need to have
some basic web design skills and then
finally you need to have your social
media skills yeah social media is a key
part of promoting your blog on the
Social Web and you need to know how to
do that you need to know how to set that
up you need to know how to create those
social media posts and how to track them
when they um when you have published
them yes so lots of skills that you need
but it doesn't mean that you need to be
an expert immediately when you start
with that yeah but it is it is important
that you recognize those topics and that
you start building experience for that
okay so if you feel that you have those
skills yeah then is that enough for you
to start creating a Blog yeah there's
some other questions that you need to
ask yourself first of all one of the
biggest questions you need to ask
there's my yourself is what am I going
to write about yeah do I have a passion
for writing and sharing my knowledge
about a certain topic do I have a
passion about a theme about a topic am I
do I have a passion about technology do
I have a passion about health yeah so
you need to have that passion because
when you start developing your blog and
writing your blog post it takes an it
takes time it takes effort and the more
passionate you are about the topic that
you write about then that time and that
effort doesn't matter you don't feel
like it's taking all that time because
you're doing something that you really
really
like you also need to have very clear
goals yeah what are you going to do with
your blog why are you having this blog
you also need to have the time and the
resources to regularly create new blog
posts yeah because there's nothing more
frustrating and nothing more damaging on
your website if you start a blog but
then after five posts you stop with it
yeah there's so many websites where you
go to and then you go to the blog and
the last blog post was 24 months ago
yeah then it almost works against you
yeah it shows hey there's a Blog but
they haven't taken the efforts to um to
start the blog yes so you need to have
that passion you need to have clear
goals now businesses they often have
very clear goals for a Blog yeah they
want to use a Blog to increase traffic
to the website to drive conversions yeah
to get people to the website to get them
to convert into a prospect it helps them
in contributing to their social media
efforts it's great way to build client
trust to be seen as an expert in their
field yep it gets a great way for
developing the brand and reinforce the
key messages around the brand it's great
to differentiate yourself from your
competitors and it is a good way to
encourage engagement with your customers
yeah so for businesses there's almost
like a no-brainer they want to they they
use blogs because they can see that they
get a lot of benefits but for you let's
take it very simple yeah there are five
reasons if you want to start your blog
there's five reasons why you can why why
you should create a blog yes first of
all if you want to express yourself
creatively then blogging is the best
place to do
this yeah so if you haven't if you are
passionate about a topic and you want to
share that knowledge then blogging is
the number one place to go to yeah
second if you want to show yourself as
an expert or build yourself as an expert
and you want to grow want to grow an
audience around this you want to grow a
follower base who are interested in
learning about what you have to say
about your topic yeah so if you want to
establish expertise and buil an audience
then you have to start using a Blog for
that sech l a reason why you must create
a blog yeah if you want to build a
community if you want to network with
other people if you want to network with
prospects get them to your website get
them to convert yeah if you want that to
grow your business then blogging is
certainly a fantastic vehicle to help
you achieve that another reason to
create a blog is that you want to
enhance your writing and your thinking
skills yeah so blogging is not writing a
book blogging is not writing an ebook
because and people may be scared of that
it may be too um too much of a uh um an
unknown field but start writing small
simple articles on your blog thereby you
develop your writing and you develop
your thinking skills very good reason
for you to start blogging you don't get
even have to publish it you can just
keep it your private blog yeah but then
when you feel comfortable you can then
start publishing it and then finally and
that's how I started as well with my own
business if you want to start making
money if you want to start your own
business yeah then a blog is a fantastic
vehicle to help position you in your
Market in your industry
yeah so it's a great vehicle that can
help you to become self-employed or make
more money so lots of reasons for you to
start creating a Blog yeah so now that
we've seen what you need yeah for
creating and start blogging yeah why you
should start blogging uh let's have a
look at the different types of blog
posts that you can create on your blog
there are many different types of post
and I'll give you a list of them in um
in a minute and each blog post each type
of blog post they serve a different
purpose and a different requirement from
the readers but there are some
reasons
that apply to every reader first of all
your blog post must provide value yeah
different readers have different
preferences to the type of content they
like to read but value is the same for
everybody yeah so if you provide value
to your readers you keep them engaged
and very important you keep them coming
back another common characteristics for
B for all blog posts is that you need to
keep them fresh and you need to keep
them interesting so it means you need to
make sure that the content is up to date
but also that you do a variety of post
types because that keeps it fresh that
keeps it interesting it also sort of
helps in breaking up the um the monotone
um sort of style of a Blog yes so use
different content Styles use different
formats use different visuals to keep
your content alive and interesting
another common element for all blog
posts is you need to cater to the
different learning
styles some people may read want to read
text-based blog posts some people may
want to see more visual content or
infographics some people may want to see
video content yeah so offer that Variety
in your blog posts so you can cater for
different type of audiences with
different type of learning styles and
then very important with a Blog and each
blog post sort of caters for that it
showcases your
Authority Yeah by offering different
types of blog posts you can demonstrate
that you're the expert regardless the
type of blog post that you do but people
will come back to your blog if they see
you as yeah this person knows what he's
talking about and that can help you
build credibility with the readers and
establish a yourself as a thought leader
in your industry yes so overall offering
a variety of different types of blog
posts can help you attract readers but
not only that you can retain your
readers and you may get them back yeah
they may become part of your audience as
long as you showcase your expertise and
keep your content fresh and
interesting so given those common
elements of blog posts let's look at
some different different types of blog
posts the most popular blog posts are
list based posts yeah they provide a
list of tips of resources or other
information on a specific topic people
love lists people love the top five
things in this or 10 things you may have
missed yeah a really good example of a
list based post is live hacker live
hacker gives you life hacks yes so nine
food labels that don't mean what you
think they mean yeah 15 ways to build a
better breakfast sandwich nine of the
most dangerous driving emergencies
little tips list of tips people love
those and the way they are presented on
this blog is actually quite interesting
yeah instead of having a long article
about this they actually have a short
introduction but they do them as
slideshows why not yeah it's visual
yeah so here is one yeah so here is the
next slide yeah so black eyes here you
see little highlight of what is uh what
what it's about yeah animals in the
road next one is a car with mattress
flapping on the rooftop may look funny
but you don't want to be behind it yes
so lots of good tips and people love
these type of
blogs the next one is thought leadership
posts so so they express the author's
thoughts or feelings on a specific topic
and particularly for businesses these
are very important because by building
thought
leadership which means being seen as an
expert in your field you're also
building trust now one of the best
thought leadership blogs in the industry
is Harvard Business Review yeah so lots
of articles on a lot of different topics
around business yeah here you see the
different categories the different media
formats yeah and here you see the
different blogs that they topic writing
about yes so generative AI can help you
tailor messaging here is the article
yeah and here you see also the call to
action that we talked about subscribe to
Harvard Business reiew yeah they have
here options to monetize the uh the blog
and here you talk about subscribe yeah
subscribe all simple call to actions
here is a summary of the article here's
the article itself we talked about that
here's the social sharing button yeah
here's the visual that they use so all
the aspects that we talked about earlier
are available in this blog yeah but
these are typical thought leadership
blogs that can really help in developing
yourself as an expert case study blogs
they are sort of blogs with articles
that give an in-depth analysis of a
single topic yeah
so typically to prove a point or back up
an argument yeah so this is kind of
background information to make your
point so good example for that is
HubSpot yeah so HubSpot is a marketing
automation system they have one of the
best blogs in the industry yeah where
they give lots of background information
on all the different social media
digital marketing topics that you can
find yeah so here you see how a homepage
of a Blog yeah can be organized that is
your featured post here you have more
featured post you see it's very visual
here you have the last sort of blog
posts here you see last categories and
the blog post call to action call to
action here yeah another category and
then to make it more exciting we'll add
videos to this page as
well yeah so good example of a case
study blog yeah and and a general blog
in with all the features that it need
you then have video and audio blogs
video becomes more and more important as
a Channel of communication yeah
so start using video
we also have seen the growth of
podcasting start using audio Yeah and
use those as part of your blogging
strategy as well here's a good example
yeah that is SoundCloud now SoundCloud
is a website which is kind of the
YouTube for audio Yeah for for uh for
podcast for audio files and here you see
their blog which a good mix of news
resources audio files blog post with
text yeah and video files as well so
it's a perfect combination of all the
elements that we're talking about here
yes so very important to use video and
audio blogs as well here are some more
types of blogs news jacking or news
posts they provide information on recent
events or developments in a specific
industry yeah so good news checking
hacking we site is wired yeah
specifically focus on
technology yeah and it is a goto place
for the latest news on
technology it's you see a very clear
style you see it on the visuals as well
yeah and is again it is a news kind of
portal yeah which gives you access to
all the blog posts it doesn't really
look like a Blog it looks like a news
portal and that is particularly for news
websites a very common way of using a
blogging platform to create a news
portal okay we're then looking at
infographics posts now you may have
heard of infographics they uh are
Graphics that simplify complex materials
with a chart graphs and and Graphics yep
and you can do blog post to own those as
well yeah one of my favorites and you
should follow them on Facebook Facebook
for and on LinkedIn the visual
capitalist the visual capitalist has a
every day they come out with a new chart
yeah or a new infographic on a
particular topic yeah so here you see
infographic on the top 50 most visited
websites in the
world so here's the infographic and then
here is the text sort of the background
information about it yeah so here's the
visual so you see Google yeah you see
YouTube Facebook Twitter so here you see
how that all sort of um how that
develops yes so with the text subscribe
to it yes so good visual
comparison so very powerful website so
use those type of websites use that type
of way of presenting your uh your
information we then look at how to posts
they offer a detailed instruction on how
to do a particular task yeah people love
those a good example of a how to block
is Seth godin's blog yep where he has
very simple design for his blog but this
is all about the content so he has a
story of the week or his top 100 posts
yeah so how to tell a great story advice
for outer how to be remarket how to
write an ebook how to do permission
marketing an email check is very down to
earth simple how to tips when it comes
to business very straightforward very
popular blog when it comes to how to
post and then last but not least a very
powerful type of blog is the guest post
yes so why would you write on your own
blog why can't to be a guest blogger on
somebody else's post has lots of
benefits from a search engine
perspective as well for the author of
The Blog because you have other websites
that recognize your um your your
expertise in your area they invite you
to write about that and Google sees that
as a high Authority ranking signal for
your search yeah good example of a um a
guest PO is Neil Patel who has its own
website has his own blog is really well
recognized as a digital marketing expert
yep and here he is writing an article as
a guest on the HubSpot blog yep so very
useful very powerful way and very
powerful type of blog post that you can
uh that you can
write okay so those are the different
blog posts so let's look at how how you
go about creating a Blog there's a
number of steps that you need to look at
first of all you need to look at what is
the CMS or the blogging platform that
you're going to use yeah it's a very
important decision for bloggers because
there's sever several sort of decisions
that you need to make here first of all
you're going to look at am I going to
use a simple
platform which is often free to begin
with or am I going professional straight
away so if you're going simple yep then
you can go for tools like
wordpress.com or wix.com they will host
the website for you and those are the
typical tools that give you some basic
functionality in the free version you
will have your website up and running
within 5 minutes but then if you want
more functionality you pay a bit
more yep now or you want to decide to go
professional which means you're going to
go to a web hosting provider and you're
going to install your own website on
their servers yep and one of the most
popular platforms for that is
wordpress.org which is a different
version of Wordpress wordpress.org yeah
gives you a lot more flexibility a lot
more freedom a lot more um plugins yeah
but it is bit more complicated to set
up yep and there is some uh the
WordPress itself doesn't cost you any
money but the hosting will cost you
money yeah the questions that you need
to ask yourself whether you want to go
simple or complex are hey um what do you
want your blog to do do you just want to
get it for your sharing your expertise
or do you want to monetize your blog
yeah do you want to run it as the
website for your business for instance
what are your technical skills do you
have very limited technical skills you
may want to go for a hosted version on
wordpress.com or Wix or Weeble yeah do
you have sufficient technical skills you
may want to go for the wordpress.org
version which is the hosted version you
need to think about your budget yeah do
you you have budget to use a hosted
platform yep and of course you need to
look at the features of the platforms
that you use can you find yourself in
the features that you want to use for
that yes so that is the first question
that you want to ask yourself where are
you going to host your website and that
is what blogging platform are you going
to use step two is you're going to look
at your domain name of course very
important that is the name of your
website the name of your blog it's a
unique web address that is identified
that identifies your blog on the
internet yeah so when you choose your
domain name make sure make make sure it
is memorable it is reflective of your
brand people recognize it it's available
on other social media websites as well
yep so it hasn't been taken by other
people on Facebook or in Instagram yeah
and maybe use your keywords that are
relevant for your blog so lots of things
that you need to do if you want to have
a domain then you can check on um on
sites like God daddy if the domain name
is
available yeah then when you have it you
can then buy it and you usually Bay the
register for a year or for two years if
it's a very simple name that hasn't
that's that is not very popular then it
often cost you maybe $10 if it is a more
popular name that hasn't been registered
yet you may pay
more okay so then you also need to think
about the extension of your domain is it
going to be a do com is it going to be a
net is it going to be a.org or is it
going to be a country extension like NL
for the Netherlands yes so um or Dot f
for France common rule is if you're
targeting a local market take the URL of
the local market if you're targeting a
global market go for the do or the net
but preferably the do if you're an organ
a government organization then you want
to usually stick to
theor then of course you will have
checked the availability of your domain
and then you're going to register the
domain yes so
you provide your contact information you
pay a small or a large fee depending on
the popularity of the name and then in
your website your blog setup you're
going to connect the domain to your blog
so that means updating the name servers
in your domain's register account so it
then points to your blog Hosting
account yeah so a very simple uh or good
provider you can go to is GoDaddy do.
or. co.uk and they give you everything
yeah so type the domain that you want
yeah they can help you create your
website they have different types of
services they do domain names they do
website and hosting and they do email
marketing they have really good
support yeah so if you want to type your
domain so let's take for instance um do
uh company ABC is going to be my
domain yep and you see here company
abc.co UK is
available yes so um there is here's the
company letter you see if you want to
use that one is a premium name so here
you see all the different varieties on
the name yeah here basic company.com
that would cost you £3,000 because it is
a quite a popular name
yeah so it is available
but yeah value for
money okay so that is your um choosing
your domain name then you're going to
look at your hosting plan and your
hosting plan is very important you will
only select a hosting plan if you go for
a
hosted uh blog solution yeah so which
you do with word press.org for instance
so basically when you select your
hosting plan you buy a bit of storage
space on the servers of that hosting
profiler and on that spit of storage
page you install your website and then
the service the hosting provider will
connect that to the Internet so they
provide the technology and the support
to store and maintain your
website yes so
that is a very important part and again
you need to consider your budget and you
also need to consider your website
requirements you need to look at the
reliability and the speed and the uptime
yeah so a reliable hosting provider they
offer you high uptime percentage and
fast loading times that is very
important yep and you need to very
carefully look at customer support yeah
so make sure they offer 247 support
preferably with a chat option because
often you have to wait a long time to
get access and if you have a chat option
is much easier to get your um to get
your problems solved and a very
important part of your hosting plan as
well is your security yeah make sure
that there is a spam protection on your
website and also look at your https yeah
so get your SSL certificate for your uh
for your
website yes so now some popular hosting
providers you can look at include
GoDaddy blue host host Gator dream host
take the time to research them yeah and
evaluate each option and certainly look
at the customer reviews as well next
step is you're going to design your blog
yeah so once you've created or you
selected your hosting provider you're
then going to set up your blog and you
would install wordpress.org yeah and
then you're going to create your website
now the first thing that most of those
CMS yeah platforms will ask you is what
theme do you want to pick and they have
a whole library of themes that you can
pick and choose from and there's lots of
websites that allow you to buy themes
whether it's a photography theme a
health theme a a business theme Y and
then you can just buy that theme install
it in your WordPress setup yep and then
you download the demo for it and then
you have your website the only thing you
have to do is change the content and the
visuals and your website is ready yes so
very important that you pick a very
powerful sort of theme you then can cust
cize the theme with your own photos your
own logo your own color schemes your own
options so you can make it a unique look
and feel you then add your own images
yeah you customize the header of the
website so and then you can use custom
widgets small Med modules that you can
add to your website that do things like
sign up for my newsletter or
um what's it click on the RSS feed of
your website Etc and then often you can
add your own sort of HTML coding or css
coding as well to give your website
additional functionality a really good
place to buy themes are is themes
forest.net yeah so there's a whole range
of themes you can say for instance give
me an entertainment themes here you see
entertainment themes could be um yeah so
you want
WordPress yeah for instance WordPress
themes and then you just pick a theme
yeah you can actually do a live preview
of the
theme yeah and this is here see the
demos we want the uh no coding so take
for instance this one here taste the
difference and here you see immediately
how your website will look like how your
blog will look
like yes so then you download the theme
install it on
WordPress download the demo and again
then the only thing you have to do is
change the text and the visuals yeah and
some Design
Elements so it's so easy there's not a
single line of programming that you have
to do these days yeah when it comes to
your web development and that is a big
concern learn that people had do I still
have to program no you don't it's all
sort of
intuitive step five start creating your
content of course when your blog is live
when your blog is up and running you
need to start creating content for your
blog to by writing posts adding images
creating Pages organizing your content
using the categories and the tags making
it easier for people to find now before
before you can start writing your post
you of course you need to know what
you're going to write about yeah what is
your focus what is your Niche what are
your interests what is your passion you
need to do keyword research around those
topics yeah so that gives you the
ability to um understand what your
target audience want to read about yeah
use tools like Google Keyword Planner
and we've done an earlier video on how
to use Google Keyword Planner to find
keywords for your blog create an
editorial calendar very important know
that every week you're going to do a
blog post yeah so every Monday you need
to draft a post Wednesday you want to
publish it yeah so look forward maybe
write four or eight blog posts in
advance and then you are ready for the
next eight weeks then start writing your
first blog post yeah that introduces the
blog and introduces your Niche create a
Content strategy have a visual strategy
and optimize your blog post for search
using the keywords yeah and using the
meta tags for your blogs so that is
really important because Google loves to
show blog posts higher up in the um in
the search results now remember it takes
time quality content takes time and
effort so take the time to research your
topics and make sure that you write
compelling and informative blog posts
and promote your content on social media
and other channels so that drives
traffic back to your
website and then finally we're going to
look at how to share your blog very
important you need to promote your blog
and you need to track your performance
yeah so share your blog on social media
platforms engage with your audience when
they have comments or when they give
feedback use email marketing to promote
your blog yeah collaborate with other
bloggers or websites in your Niche try
to get those blogging those guest
blogging opportunities and use paid
advertising to promote your
blog yes so it's an ongoing effort and
it requires consistent effort yeah on
the tracking site use Google analytics
so set up your blog with Google
analytics so you get information about
traffic about your audience and um about
your most popular pages and your most
popular blog posts yeah so you can track
specific actions in Google analytics so
how many people are at signing up for
the newsletter for instance monitor your
social media analytics how popular are
your blog post uh the Facebook post
about your blog on Twitter or on
Facebook or on Instagram yeah look at
open rates click through rates and
regularly review your blog's performance
and adjust your strategy if
necessary yes so very important part
don't keep your blog a secret start
promoting it high and
wide Okay so let's close the session
with some writing
tips first of all know your
audience understand who is your target
audience and what are they looking for
in your blog yeah we talked about
customer personas create customer
personas for your key audiences yep and
you're writing for them you're not
writing for yourself you need to hit the
language that resonates with your
audience
be authentic writing your own voice let
your personality shine through don't
write Anonymous yeah people want to see
the writer the author behind the art the
um the uh the article yeah make sure
that you research your topic because
that will help you in writing
authorative and then when you write
authoritatively you provide value to
your readers don't limit yourself to
text use images use videos to supplement
your writing make your blog visually
appealing it goes without saying edit
prove read prove read prove read there's
nothing more frustrating than typos in
your blog posts yeah make sure your
writing is clear it is simple it is
polished and there's no typos in there
just copy your blog text put it in a
word processor yep and then do a
spelling checker then finally be
consistent consistency is key to
building your audience and for your
readers to come back yes so and be
consistent in the timing as well try to
do it daily or weekly or monthly but
give that consistency to your
readers and if you take all these things
together and you are passionate about a
topic then I'm sure you're going to be
successful with your blog content
marketing is becoming a key player in
the digital marketing domain if you are
looking to grab a successful career in
content marketing but not limited to
content marketing simply learn has got
you covered with wide range of topnotch
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with handson on experience in
tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner Sam rush and there is a huge
list on the board however one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
this course find the course Link in the
description box people may experience
various difficulties in writing blogs
articles or copyrights for example some
may struggle to find a time to sit down
and write something out or they may
struggle to get the creative ideas
flowing and think of something new and
interesting to write about whatever the
difficulty is but it is essential to
move around and try to write something
that you are proud of it may not be
perfect but it is unique to you and can
be a great way to express yourself so if
you are looking for a free AI writing
tool that will automate your articles
blogs or copyrights Etc you have come to
the right place this video will
introduce you to a top five free AI
writing tools available a today on that
note welcome to Simply Lear if you new
to the Channel please subscribe to our
simply learn YouTube channel and click
the Bell icon to be the first one to
know about the latest trending videos
now without further delay let's see the
top five free AI writing tools or
websites the first one is writer me
writer is an AI writing tool that can
generate many different types of content
this can be used for website
copyrighting creating marketing and
sales copy writing full blog post and
many more here you can generate 10,000
characters per month which means you can
write up to 10,000 characters every
month and once your 10,000 characters of
that particular month is completed it
will be restored in the next month and
personally I recommend this tool to
write any types of copyrighting the link
below in the description will directly
take you to the writer's free plan sign
up to the website and enjoy the free
plan of writer and the second one is
jer. jper can write virginal content
create creatively including blogs
articles social media Post website copy
Etc to claim a free access to justo
please click on the link in the
description here you can claim up to
10,000 words for free that is you can
write up to 10,000 words available in
its free plan most of the people don't
use their free trial of jper because
while logging into the website it will
ask for the credit card number but you
can give the credit card number because
unless and until you complete your free
trial and shift to premium the money
won't be deducted if you like the
feature of jper you can continue with
the premium if not log out from the
website and the third one is right Sonic
right Sonic is an AI powered copyright
tool that will generate a unique and
engaging marketing content for any types
of business insights with the few lens
of text right Sonic will generate ads
block post landing pages product
description and menu here you will get a
free trial for all the features with 6
to 50 words per user once you done with
a free TR you can op the Premium plan
which is available for
1267 where you will get 4,500 words per
user the link mentioned Below in the
description will directly take you the
free plan of right Sonic and the fourth
one is right cream the right cream is a
creative AI powered marketing tool that
utilize the advanced machine learning to
write a copy of Google ads landing pages
product descriptions blog post social
media and many more here you will get up
to 20 credits that is 40,000 characters
in which you can write two long articles
of 5,000 words and four short articles
of th000 words if you are comfortable
with the right cream you can go for its
Premium plan which charges $29 per month
and right cream has an amazing offer of
getting all these features for Lifetime
only for $59 us and the last one is
scaler it is the combination of Next
Generation Technologies like Ai and NLP
and the sess content creation process to
create a Content that exceeds the RIS it
enables you to improve your contents
readability efficiency and overall
output you can get a trial of scale nut
by clicking on the link below in the
description here you will get 2,000
words 40 plus AI tools two SEO reports
and menu you can also go for the pre
Premium plan for 924 rupees per month
with this we have reached the end of
this session today we learn top five
ating tools that will help you write any
copyright starting out what are the
essential components of a good web
content okay so essential components
okay so what do we want our content to
do well we want it to be useful so web
content should be written in a way which
caters to what the reader wants okay so
somebody's not going to read your
content if it's not useful for them okay
this because it affects reader
engagement okay so if it's not
interesting it's not useful somebody's
just not going to read it plain and
simple it also has to be engaging so
listen even if it is relevant to a user
you still have to write the content so
it's engaging so you want to add
elements like imagery videos hey you
could even turn your content into an
infographic okay you want to do
something that's going to be engaging
for the user if it's engaging they're
going to read it and engage with with
the content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know I've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and end with good content but it
doesn't leave a user with anywhere to go
so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after you're done
engaging with the good content that you
write okay so some other things to think
think about some other components for
good content well credibility so you
know anybody can write but are you
writing about something you know what
you're writing about are you a good
talking point a good expert or have
experience about this content so you
also want to use you know information
from a legitimate Source okay so you
don't want to grab something and your
and use it in your content that's just
not legitimate because it does hurt your
credibility and the organization's
credibility and then also originality I
mean write something that nobody else
has written so obviously you don't want
to plagiarize because if you're
plagiarized and there are tools out
there where people can easily just put
their content in there to see what else
is out there see if somebody else has
plagiarized it so it's very easy to find
people who plagiarized so don't be that
person what I would recommend create a
good content calendar and come up some
ideas before you write them next
question related to content marketing so
what what are the types of content you
can create well there are a lot of
things you can create start with the
blog blog to me is always a great place
to start it's a blank canvas for your
ideas your thoughts your opinions okay
that's a great thing about a Blog it it
accentuates personality you can create a
video videos are always engaging you can
create an infographic infographics to me
are you know Hidden Gem instead of
somebody reading the same old same old
you're laying this out in a very visual
away that's easy to understand create a
case study okay so if you're you digital
marketing expert you done social media
for another client you know write about
it you know show the successes show that
you are an expert show that you've
created successful campaigns and social
in in the form of a case study you can
create a white paper white papers are
are good educational pieces you can also
create an ebook Okay ebook hey if you
have a lot of content you want to lay it
out an ebook is a good way to go mean
you have a lot of choices here when it
comes to content a lot of choices okay
so what are the advantages of having a
Content calendar so I alluded to that
just a couple of seconds ago so let's
really break this down here cuz content
calendars to me are so important well
first of all calendar part of content
calendar allows you to think about dates
so if you're planning something you're
going to have important dates in mind
okay so content calendar it almost
ensures you don't miss anything you know
that's a good opportunity for you you to
leverage like you know Black Friday
Cyber Monday you know it's probably
important you know when those days are
if you're in e-commerce so that's why
having a Content calendar helps it helps
you plan out your content based on
important dates or based on dates that
work for what you're trying to do they
also help because you could stick to a
consistent schedule okay so if you don't
have a Content calendar you're probably
just arbitrarily writing content here
and there well what if your users crave
and really engage their content they're
going to want more sticking to something
consistent is going to really get people
to come back for more they know when
you're going to post they're going to be
waiting for it and if it's every Tuesday
morning 8:00 hey post it Tuesday morning
8:00 your users will get used to that
schedule and it it does help build up
your following it does help help build
up your community and in the end
cultivates a longlasting relationship
and having a Content calendar also
allows you to mix up your content okay
so you can see and plan ahead different
types of content in different formats
that way it allows you to mix it up
whether it be a blog post uh an
infographic a video about different
topics okay some other advantages here
saving time it just allows you to
prepare for the future when you can
prepare you're efficient and when you're
efficient you're not wasting time and so
to me having a Content calendar is a
must because a lot of us are busy who
has time and especially if you're going
to work in a new company let's say
writing content you definitely want to
have a Content calendar because you're
going to want to use that time to
efficiently plan this is a new company
you're going to start working at you
want to understand who this company is
what they've done in the past what you
haven't done and what you want to do
okay so all of that helps you plan and
prepare and it saves you the time and
effort and hassle down the road and then
at the end of the day you you want to be
able to figure out what works so
planning your post puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or that topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh again
you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again so it could be just simply
Twitter if you're putting a Content
calendar and and together for Twitter
well you don't want to have the same
tweets every other day so it does ensure
that you're getting tweets out there
that are fresh that are new that are
different and again figure out what
works a Content counter makes it easier
to measure results and optimize
performance so you always want to you
know maybe put some metrics in with your
content calendar so you can see side by
side content historically that is
performed content that is not performed
okay so next question you may get what
type of content Works in each stage of
the customer life cycle so you have
awareness engagement purchase postp
purchase advocacy okay so let's break
these down here so awareness okay so you
want people to understand who you are
okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping you out it could be a
old email a v a video that can
potentially go viral a social media post
introducing a product you have
engagement so you want people to engage
with your content what are you going to
do to get people to engage well you
could certainly write an email and have
people open that email and go to your
website you can have an ebook where
people can actually download and read it
or you can have a Blog where people can
comment or Lanny page where they can
fill out a form submission you have a
evaluation so with social media we know
there's a lot of Engagement going on but
when you're putting content out there
you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case studies a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you worked in a for a
specific product in the past and it's
worked you certainly want to put that
out there for potential clients in that
same industry purchase trying to get
people to purchase what are you going to
do well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know webs site a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and service details as
well meaning you know One onepage
downloadable PDFs that describe the
product okay you have postp purchase
okay so people who've already purchased
you could certainly send out follow-up
emails you can do blog roundups you know
give people an opportunity to see what
features or updat are happening to the
product okay of course case studies of
repeat customers or content types that
detail a new feature or service and so
if somebody's already purchased hey you
may want to send them some content of
another product that complements the
product they bought so a lot of things
you can do to engage with your user
who's already purchased and then
advocacy you want people to help you out
here so have the user generate the
content you can have exclusive discounts
for your community Community they're
going to be your Advocates so give them
exclusive discounts and then pictures of
customers engaging with your products
okay who's not going to share that so
you're going to have people share that
information in other words you can
generate content where you hey people
can help you out here and be your
Advocate okay so how do you decide what
topic and subject to write on okay well
going back to the content calter that
always helps you can see what you've put
in that content calendar but there are
some other methods you can use and you
can certainly identify your target
audience and not only identify your
target audience but what their needs are
okay so you can write content based on
audience so you could certainly do some
research with keywords okay what's
trending what keywords are not trending
okay and write around what's trending
for example okay you could certainly
take a look at social media for example
Kora I always look at Kora Kora is
interesting entertaining informational
and people are certainly having
conversations on Kora and you can
certainly Analyze This conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do I want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in depth so some other things
you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitor's blogs or or your
competitor's social media platforms and
Pages you can keep track of blogs and
articles from subject matter experts
comment critics and so on okay so you
can get ideas from them another question
you may get which is very important if
you're going to start working for a
company you need to understand the tone
the tone of your content because that is
going to fit and be in line with the
company you're working for okay so
you're always going to have a brand
personality so the characteristics of a
brand are the guidelines based on which
the content strategy is develop the tone
of the content must align itself to the
content strategy your audience profile
so you got you need to determine who
your audience is okay and how the brand
wants to be seen by that audience so you
know if you have an older audience
you're not going to use younger audience
I.E street lingo or today's lingo and in
the younger generation uh you're going
to use you know language that's going to
fit the audience you're talking to and
then of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel and consistent with brand
at attributes okay so you got to pick
and choose the channel if it's LinkedIn
for example hey you know linkedin's more
business oriented okay so you're not
going to be you know as humorous as you
would be say on Instagram or Facebook
all of these have one thing in common
again that's brand guidelines you have
to stay within the brand what is the
Brand's personality how do we want to
talk to our audience and what platform
we're using to talk to our audience how
do you promote your content once it's
Live Well that's it's always a good
question hey you doing the the work the
putting in the hard work to create this
you know it could be a video and videos
take a long time it could be an
infographic an ebook Okay so send it out
via email okay if you have an an email
list send it out and let people know
this content's there put a link in the
email or or even a piece or snippet or
preview of the content in the email so
you're using the email to broadcast and
encourage people to you know if it's an
ebook get the rest of the EB okay you
can certainly leverage social media to
engage with your community that's the
best you know just as good as email get
out there and let people know hey I got
I got my book published come and
download it you know you can give a
discount to the first 100 people that
download it okay you can always promote
your content via ads so whether that be
Google or Facebook you always have an
opportunity to meet more prominent by
advertising the content that you have to
offer so you can always Reach Out out on
social media again targeting interesting
people directly so you can always
interact with people on social or you
can write for others attract people from
the web to important pages of your
website by guest posting so you can
always go onto a popular blog post and
write something and you know link it up
or or have it be relevant to the content
you've written so next question H how
can you determine how well your content
is doing okay very important again
you've done all the work work you put
the content calendar together you got
the content ready to go it's published
you're promoting it social email guest
blogging but you want to determine how
it's doing well depends on the channel
really is what it comes down to so if
it's organic sech you want to be able to
see if it's ranking for the keyword you
optimize that content for if it's social
you want to be able to see if you have
engagement shares comments Etc of course
you can always look at Analytics
and see how much traffic that blog post
is getting or that page with the white
paper is getting okay so you can always
look at your analytics and look at the
traffic okay and again you can always
look to see if there are conversions in
the form of an inquiry or lead or sale
so at the end of the day you want to
align the content with the channel and
you want to align the kpi with the
content in Channel okay so if it's
social you're not likely going to get
conversion unless you're doing paid ads
if you're posting organically on social
then you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with your content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what I was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes you need to
Define buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so you're always writing for an
audience and you're going to Market that
content for that audience so you always
got to keep that in mind okay run
content audience audits to determine the
best type of content that can be used in
other words how did it perform what kind
of Engagement did you get with the
infographic or did that video really
really perform well or do we want to use
you know a blog post next time around or
an image next time around so continuing
on here you want to choose an
appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it WordPress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
calendar to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you you
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to choose the format and
then of course you want to publish and
manage your content after it's all said
and done so these are the steps involved
again just quickly decide on the goal
the kpi decide on your audience look at
what's worked and not worked in the past
get your content set up in the platform
okay or get the platform ready to go I
should say okay generate ideas with that
content calendar I ideally go to the
content calendar for the ideas choose
that type and then publish and manage
and when I say manage I mean again going
back to analytics or going back to the
kpi that you align with that content to
see if it's performing or not okay so
next question here how do you target the
Right audience for your content so very
good question you're not writing content
for everyone let's be honest here so you
have to collect demographic grac of your
target audience based on who's coming to
your website based on who subscribed to
your emails based on who's following you
on social media so in other words you
have people interacting with you okay in
different channels and you need to
understand who these people are so are
they fit a certain age range or
generation are they skewed more female
to male education level what's their
finity or interest okay do they have a
certain income so you need to really
break down your audience here and you
could do that in analytics you could do
that on social you can do that just by
looking at your email list okay the all
those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is so here we wrap up
content marketing course if you have any
queries regarding any concepts in if you
have any queries regarding any Concept
in the video feel free to add it in the
comment section and our experts will be
happy to help you do subscribe to Simply
learn to stay updated with new
technology Trends thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here